so between Arthur and foul play just
normal dialogue had change for normal
people and and different words that come
into play you also you know I've not
seen the remake of Arthur which flopped
but my guess is that things that made
Arthur work completely in whatever year
that was right the original work now
those things don't don't work now they
you know it's the story sometimes
becomes the wrong time story sorry um
also you know you can't replace John
Gielgud with anybody you know usually to
meet someone like this one must go to a
bowling alley you know I'm I'll alert
the media you know it's like this is a
guy that has that delivery that can make
those lines sing where you know these
days you know some other actor that's
one of the weird problems with remixes
often what happens is a remake was six
of movie was successful because it wants
but particular actor and one particular
time period and when you change the time
period and the actor it no longer works
Footloose Footloose absolutely there is
a there's a great example 12 year old
going to the theater seeing Kevin Bacon
what loose yeah absolutely works the
original works remake not so much and
you the the thing with generational
dialogue is one of those things where
you know a piece of slang or a line that
works at one period of time doesn't work
in the next period of time which is why
sometimes it's better just to make up
your own slang or you're on whatever
right but also to the problems of one
generation or to be totally different
because at that time Lori singers dad
didn't want her dancing exactly didn't
want her with the Kevin Bacon character
nowadays probably would be on the same
level but there'd be something different
the dad would be going on somebody's
Instagram seeing I don't like the photos
he's posting so it doesn't translate
which which brings up yet which brings
up another thing is you know again this
may not have anything to do with it but
we allow we now live in a world where
there are everyone's got a computer in
their pocket everyone's got all of these
things so often what happens with a
remake that gets updated is all of those
things that we didn't have
then we do have now and it has to change
the way the story works which means
which means it's probably not a good
idea to do remakes but I don't think
Hollywood's going to listen to anyone
about that and the you know the the
remakes if you're doing a remake you
have to be prepared to figure out what
the essence of why that film worked is
and then adapt that everything except
that essence and that is often the tough
part with Hollywood is they think that
it's you know I have this this thing at
my a friend of Mines cousin wrote a
script and the producer said this what
this script needs is a donkey in it and
he's like Oh what because a donkey in it
because um bachelor party had a donkey
and it made money and they be with them
though the list of movies with donkeys
that made money you're like this
producer has the weirdest narrow tunnel
vision of donkey you know films with
donkeys make money look at all these
examples you're like I don't think there
was the donkey that was the maid all is
calm successful but that's into being
producer thought is that it's some weird
specific to what the movie is rather
than something underneath that that's
deeper that goes into rebellion or you
know all of these things that might be
the you know that again man I haven't
see Footloose since it came out probably
but the idea of the sophisticated City
type guy going to the small town where
everything is very formal and he is the
more rebellious guy and so he basically
creates this rebellion through dance
thank you know and that that formal
world I don't think we have much of that
anymore because of communications I mean
the the kids in that small in a small
town before we you couldn't turn on the
TV and see all kinds of stuff you they
weren't listening to hip-hop you know
this hip hip hop probably dates me huh
that's a nice they were listening to rap
see this is it and there's a problem see
what if you were to take some story that
was hip-hop story and try to adapt it
for now it's like that's old that's you
know but but kids today can go on can go
on YouTube and see everything so they're
not
you know the the problem with with you
know remaking Footloose is that those
kids are already exposed to all that
music so being a rebel and showing them
dance and showing them all this stuff
can't work they already know all this
stuff exists though the world is a you
know a bigger place we can now go on
youtube and watch something that's
happening in another culture all the way
across the world and that becomes part
of our lives sometimes sure and have
instant updates about it yeah so those
things make it tough to write scripts
sometimes you know the the the cell
phone made it tough to write horror
movies because the question always
became why don't they just call the cops
and everything and my solution to that
is always they do they don't have
service no they don't have services is I
think is the thing that although I never
have service any place so it's like you
know the serial killer attacked me you
know I tried to call the cops it would
be like no service hell I'm like a cross
from a verizon store but which actually
there are there's a verizon store where
you have no cell service for verizon but
it's in the valley but the the thing
that I always do is I have them connect
so I have a horror story where they she
connects to the police and the police
don't believe the damn things she's
saying because she's saying you know
there's a it's not a guy in a hockey
mask but you know we can say this guy in
a hockey mask with a machete that's been
killing us one by one there's a good
chance the police won't believe that but
there's a great movie from man probably
the 70s or early 80s called The
Stepfather which has been remade in a
bad version but the original has a great
scene where the female lead last to die
picks up the phone calls the police gets
through of course you know home phone
calls the police and then the police
officer comes and you think it's the
cavalry she saved killed so now it works
even twice as good because now we have
the authority figure comes and they're
taken off the table so now even the
authorities cannot stop this killer
which works
you